hey guys Dennis here the founder of
think here and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the season 4
finale of Boardwalk Empire
farewell daddy blues yeah so you know
this is one of my favorite television
shows right now and this is a different
finale than I was kind of expecting I
was kind of expecting I probably should
have seen it coming because of a last
week's episode but this was not like a
big conclusion like last no big
shootouts room no big shoot it has no
big you know wrap up of stuff a lot of
stuff was unsettled yeah yeah this is
definitely setting up for season 5 for
next year some deaths you know yeah not
the way we expected it to happen no well
let's start off with one of my favorite
characters I think this character and
Richard Harrow half face him and chalk
here my favorite character so Richard
Harrow is dead you got shake yeah a
little got some jitters there hesitated
hesitated and just like you know it's
also an accident you know no see
Chalky's my daughter go in there but
yeah he didn't actually even get hit
with too many shots a few shots maybe to
the body and then I thought goes but I
mean you know it's Torrio and get shot
about five times it'd be about 80 years
old he's fine ya know so yeah it sucks
cuz now he's dead but I guess either two
things we're gonna happen either he's
gonna die like he did in this episode
right or he would actually three things
or he would have gone back to Wisconsin
and lived his regular life and then we
just wouldn't see him again right in the
show yeah like he lived that happy we
ever after but I guess that probably
wasn't possible right and the third
option was he works for Nucky and he
becomes you know gray like some sort of
assassin for him yeah and I think I like
the way you went out I think you went
out well yeah a nice little dream
sequence gonna see a normal face and
yeah it's 70 left but I mean I think we
are moving towards the development of
Luciano and Capone and seeing these guys
finally rise to power they're probably
I'm assuming season five this year so
let's talk about though
resolve things yeah which is you know
with chalky we saw the big shootout the
club and then dr. Narcisse we thought
like okay one of these two are gonna go
down preferably dr. Narcisse because we
like chalky right but it kind of ended
in a you know not a stalemate but like
it's unresolved cuz we got brighter we
got chalky back at his mentor's
house like probably gearing up for war
right Nucky was trying to help him out
but again it went horribly wrong and his
daughter said but he can't get revenge
on Harrow Haros gone yeah and he knows
here I was taking a shot as he looked up
ya see him so I mean I I don't know he's
back with his mentor Louis Gossett jr.
place and you know his girls down there
singing on the club so yeah now he's got
his own COO seems like he's the bend his
family for the most part he sells a wife
and the son well I'm sure he's like
messed up in the head yeah and but then
dr. Narcisse on their hand is Sora he's
basically gonna rat on his like some guy
that he like really admires
yeah and so that he will stay out of
prison right so when it comes down to it
he he is like this kind of shady
businessman he's a survivor
yeah he knows that's the one way you can
somebody he tries to portray himself
it's like he's a moment mission and like
all this stuff but if you know he was he
probably would be like no I'm just gonna
stay in jail right this guy out but he
knows like look I don't want to spend
the rest of my life in prison
I guess I'll you know race that way I
can do what I actually wanted to do and
I'm kind of glad that Hoover's gonna be
a bigger part because he's that kid the
guy what's his name the the younger guy
the the other Tolliver Tolliver he was
getting a little bit annoying towards
you like he's always just whining man
you've always been
against me ever since the law school the
other guy into the guy in the hotel I
was like you you and Hoover been left
behind my back he's always just
complainin I want to be like relaxed
like it's just so I'm glad that Hoover's
more of a I like Hoover's character like
the actor you know from the HBO series
which was in generation Generation Kill
I like him so I'm glad that we're gonna
see more Hoover next season oh it's been
speaking of Tolliver
he went out right yeah
another gritty fight great fight just
like just like the Don purnsley Barret
is charging fight this was an Eli vs
Tolliver was like another gritty like
choking yeah over the head whatever it
hurt his daughter was playing the whoo
we did the song thing so yeah it was a
good fight another great fight yeah so
and then we now see Eli he's not dead
because he almost got killed by Nucky
right right and but we get to see that
he gets us live another day this time is
it's kind of like the thing like all
right we'll just ship him to Chicago
because there's weather with Jimmy Jimmy
was in trouble
they're like okay let's get Jimmy out of
town let's go to Chicago I guess that's
considered West for them yeah Wes yeah
the bill was so now next season we see
Michael Shannon's character bein old and
picked up Eli so that's another setup
right for next season and it feels like
I know there are predictions later but
it feels like two there I mean I assume
they gonna keep the show in Atlantic
City but the thing is there's really not
much left there I mean for him to do I
mean the mayor guy he's not even really
a character anymore like all the
politicians used to deal with he doesn't
even talk to anymore I wonder how much
time resting has spent in Atlantic City
or if they are gonna focus on Chicago
New York and maybe Florida who knows but
another character was hoping we would
get some resolve for him and didn't his
Jillian I was kind of hoping we were
just like I wonder I just I hope I hope
it's resolved he could still because she
was in prison and they gave her the news
I guess probably of them finding Jimmy's
body right that's not I'm assuming that
that Nucky gave up that information it
was not sure what's left for her to do
I'm hoping that that was the last of her
that we've seen her in prison and that's
that maybe that's resolved because I
know I I don't think we really needed
her this season and we definitely I
don't see any storyline for next season
the only thing I'm worried though is
that maybe Hoover he gets wind of her
and then tries to turn her and say hey
we'll get you out earlier if you testify
I don't know how much information she
has on Nucky but I'm hoping I don't I
don't think she has much and I think she
has my old
but in two we look we see Margaret at
the end because we were wondering Harry
briefly at very briefly it looks like
Rothstein is all like playing house over
there's all like loving the little
daughter and like he's doing he's doing
what Nucky did right yeah like okay
here's this woman that has already has a
family you know you know attractive and
nice person and I want to have that
family as well but taking care of her
yeah cuz Nucky guy he's got his own girl
but don't know what that's gonna end up
like I mean that's interesting so we'll
see where that goes but yeah this was
definitely more of a setup than a
conclusion and then damn it was
definitely set up they must have known
like oh we're having a season another
you don't write that finale if this was
if any chance that this was the last
scene right yeah I mean they must have
not been worried about cuz last season's
finale you could have ended the series
sure if you wanted right I didn't want
it to but you could have this one you
can I mean everything's set up you got
Al Capone taking over Chicago with
Johnny Torrio being you know and they
still really haven't like confirmed if
if Capone was behind that or not this
kind of left or the guys like love you
win I'm out yeah and we didn't see
didn't see Meyer we can see look at the
chioma's area missouria so there's still
a lot I'm gonna see probably next season
Trish Arquette you're gonna be around
still done for there I'm assuming though
show her and is nothing gonna go down to
floor I'm sure could he said at the end
I don't know if he meant the whole
family or just the son he said Oh we'll
go up and meet you know save the family
for now we'll go up and meet your father
and a little bit so I'm like are they
all moving up there like I'd sort of
curious like what's in what's gonna be
in Atlantic City for him to do um I
don't know I don't think his family's
gonna move up there because they're
gonna follow his family yeah and because
there's looking for you killed a federal
officer yeah so yeah I think Nucky can
only sneak well up there right am
and whatnot right yeah and then you know
and what's what's nothing gonna do you
know is he still gonna be caught in this
he wants out he wants out but he's still
kind of caught up because I think by now
dr. Narcisse knows that that that he was
never on his side he was on charketa
died mm-hmm
even though it was a botched
assassination right so maybe Nucky gets
caught up in that yeah I don't know it's
gonna be soon to see you next season I
mean I really I was intense for the last
two or three years I really want more
New York and Chicago my love I know the
show is resolved on Nucky but Nucky can
be kind of a window into that world in
the Chicago with Luciano and Capone I
want to see their rides even I know the
show is not about them but I want to see
that happen I hope we're gonna get this
this shows not gonna go forever so it's
a season five next year so hope yeah
yeah it's probably gonna get one or two
more seasons right yes probably probably
probably I mean next season might be the
last season right not sure right but if
they do hopefully they tie you know it's
kind of like not as you know as
disappointing as last season's Walking
Dead finale but in a way it's similar in
that there's a lot of unresolved stuff
right and it's not like a true
conclusion to the storylines that we had
set up yeah it almost like seems like
this is a two season arc right thank
maybe also they're setting up for maybe
come next season will be the last season
if it is that's fine I mean I don't mind
them ending early I just I hope the ex
season 10 is of the meet I hope we get a
lot of story development and less
building up to something you know
obviously all right guys so that's what
we thought of the season finale of
Boardwalk Empire what did you think did
you love it did you were you
disappointed what do you think about all
the things going on what do you think
about the deaths I mean come on
Richard Harry he's like my own one of my
favorite characters on television yeah
oh and best fight rate your best fight
of the of the season
was it the chalky and Don purnsley fight
or was it uh Eli versus tolerant right
there pretty good also pretty good you
can post your comments below on the
website thank CARICOM on our youtube
channel think AeroPro make sure you
subscribe to that you also find us on
twitter Dennison I talked to us about
what you felt about the season other
shows you might be checking out right
now we're both at think here oh I'm at
Griffin de and we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash
Kiril fans make sure you like that page
make sure you subscribe to our YouTube
channel like our videos share them tweet
them and all that stuff it really helps
out